All right. We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David David Pakman,
this voicemail is very interesting in terms of
what it suggests could become the dividing line
between the vaccinated and the unvaccinated
in the future. Take a listen to this
there, David. This is Lance calling from San Jose,
listening to your show today. You're talking about
Republican reluctance to get the vaccine to
whatever denies them, denied coverage or to own
the lives. I have a crazy prediction for probably
later this year. Yeah. That covid deaths will
have to be reported based on red and blue covid
deaths or supporter, covid and supporter, really,
if it really can get the vaccine. Oh, boy, I
just stay away from Alabama and places like that.
Yeah. So, I mean, listen, you're never really
going to be able to say red or blue covid deaths
in the sense that we won't know the political
orientation of those who continue dying even
after the vaccines are widely available. And
you can't really go by state because, you know,
a Texas covid death could be some liberal in
Austin or it could be. You know what? You're
not going to know that. But the point is a good
one. Even if we won't know for sure if the most
anti vaccine group in the United States, the two
most anti vaccine groups, are Republican men.
And Trump supporters, you at a certain
point will have a significantly higher
degree of protection from the virus among
non Trump supporters and non Republicans,
and it could well be the case that in a year
or whenever vaccines are widely available,
maybe we already have a booster that accounts
for the variants. The group that will be
disproportionately unvaccinated may well be
Republicans, right wingers and Trump supporters.
And you could see a situation in the US where
like 80 percent of the deaths, 85 percent of the
deaths are right wingers. That certainly could
be the case if the anti-tax movement is going
to continue on covid remember, other anti like
measles has left and right wing anti vaccine ism
uncovered. The anti Voxer ism is far more on the
right than the left left. You could indeed start
to see that split. And I don't want anybody
to die. I don't want anybody to get sick,
even if they're ignorant anti-tax Republicans. So
I would take no pleasure in that. Let's just hope
people realize the importance of getting
vaccinated. We have a fantastic bonus show
for you today. Fox News is claiming that reports
about the Georgia Trump phone calls were wrong
and that now everybody is having to retract
the stories on them. That's not what's going
on. I'll explain the story to you on the bonus
show. We will also talk about, you know, for all
the discussion of the regular minimum wage, the
tipped minimum wage has been just over two dollars
an hour for decades, and it is not getting a lot
of discussion in the minimum wage discussions.
And then lastly, the FCC is cracking down on
robo calls with record fines. Will this make a
difference? I have some robo call stories to tell
as well. All of those stories and more on today's
bonus show. Get instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at Join Pakman dot com.